[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du Grand JT des territoires
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité vous êtes peut-être déjà un
habitué ou un passe de le devenir les
camping-cars ont la côte auprès des
Français les ventes s'envolent depuis la
crise sanitaire une tendance que nous
confirmera Moselle TV dès le début de ce
journal sa passion à lui n'a rien d'une
tendance les caméras de TL7 dans la
Loire ont filmé la collection
impressionnante d'un amoureux des années
60 une plongée dans nos souvenirs à
suivre dans quelques instants dans ce
journal puis enfin l'édition via
Occitanie nous emmènera dans les
carrières titanesque de marbre du
Languedoc c'est ici qui est extraite
l'une des plus belles roches du monde un
reportage époustouflant vous le verrez
dans un instant
vous en avez croisé c'est sûr sur la
route ou près de votre lieu de vacances
les camping-cars à la fois véhicules et
logements séduisent de plus en plus de
Français leur côté pratique attire de
nouveaux publics malgré un coup d'achat
qui peut être très élevé vous allez le
voir les immatriculations ont bondit de
23% en un an exemple en Moselle avec ce
sujet de Coline l'expert pour Moselle
télévision regardez
séduit par ses premières vacances
nomades durant la crise sanitaire Daniel
a depuis franchi le cap et acheté son
propre camping-car c'est la liberté
c'est
j'ai envie de faire du sauvage je peux
faire du sauvage et j'ai un panneau
solaire j'ai une autonomie de 100 litres
donc je peux prendre mes douches j'ai du
gaz je peux me faire à manger ce qui m'a
plu c'est d'être à la mer j'ai ouvert
mon auvent j'ai sorti mes deux fauteuils
et puis j'étais face à la mer à 20
mètres et ça il y a pas de il y a pas de
prix si le confort et l'évasion qu'offre
le camping-car à succonquerir le cœur de
Daniel d'autres adeptes comme Corinne il
voit surtout le moyen d'être dépaysé
plus souvent un hôtel on y va peut-être
une fois dans l'année quoi huit jours
dans l'année quand on peut se le
permettre jusque là il y a quelque chose
dans le coin ou n'importe quoi on saute
dedans on s'en va et ce sont plus de 500
000 camping-cars qui circulent en France
le marché est en plein boom avec 100000
véhicules vendus l'année dernière ainsi
qu'un ravissement de la clientèle car en
plus des habituels retraités coupe les
familles selon stoc aussi dans aventure
mais le secteur peine à satisfaire
toutes les demandes on a connu une belle
augmentation de nos ventes c'est un fait
maintenant on est aussi pénalisé par
l'effet covid aussi nos constructeurs
ont du mal à s'approvisionner en châssis
donc même si l'affluence de clients est
là certaines ventes malheureusement ne
peuvent pas se faire à cause de ça des
véhicules que ce Concessionnaire vont en
moyenne 65000 euros auxquels s'ajoutent
annuellement environ 650 euros
d'entretien et d'assurance mais ces
frais ne décourage pas les vacanciers
toujours plus nombreux comme au camping
municipal de Metz à l'heure actuelle on
a 65 places qui sont prises en grosse
partie par les camping-cars nous allons
vont prévu d'autres aménagements nous
sommes en train de terminer l'aire de
camping-car pour les gens qui ne
désirent pas vraiment entrer dans le
camping qui veulent rester une seule
nuit on essaie de tous les ans de
s'améliorer de faire de nouveaux travaux
pour attirer de plus en plus les gens et
pour ceux qui souhaitent s'essayer à
l'aventure de nombreux concessionnaires
et particuliers proposent de la location
une option vers laquelle se tournera
peut-être le fils de vous voulez me le
prendre mais je lui dis non tu as encore
un peu trop jeune
[Rires]
le monde de l'automobile vous le savez
et traversé par de nombreuses autres
tendances la plus emblématique d'entre
elles celle de l'électrique à ce propos
connaissez-vous le rétrophyte alors si
ce mot ne vous dit rien sans concept
pour lui vous intéresser il s'agit de
transformer votre voiture essence ou
diesel en véhiculer électrique c'est la
promesse de retrofit une solution prisée
avec la flambée des prix de l'essence et
à l'heure de la transition énergétique
un reportage en Bretagne de Tébéo la
chaîne du groupe télégramme
cette utilité a plus de 10 ans et
fonctionne sans bruit et pour cause il
est électrique
idem pour cette 504 coupée de 1970 des
véhicules thermiques anciens qui n'ont
plus de moteur essence mais des
batteries sous le capot c'est le
rétrofit avait été interdit depuis 1954
donc d'être faisable en France avec un
accord constructeur qu'il fallait pour
pouvoir changer nos motorisation et
c'est ce que nous avons cassé en créant
la filière du rétrophie électrique et en
créant une réglementation avec le
ministère de des transports de
l'écologie et tous les services
d'homologation la société qui installe
ces moteurs électriques fait un tour de
France pour convaincre des bénéfices du
rétrophyte le rétrophyte séduit cette
famille prêt à en faire une activité
professionnelle ça permet dans un
premier temps d'éventuellement continuer
à faire rouler des véhicules anciens qui
donc ont des vieilles technologies
et qui à cause des nouveaux critères
d'entrée en ville non plus le droit de
rouler et donc ça ça peut éventuellement
éviter de laisser prendre la poussière
dans un entrepôt outre avantage du
retrofit son coût par rapport à l'achat
d'un véhicule neuf électrique ce qui a
séduit la banque partenaire du tour le
rétrofit présente le grand avantage
d'être moins onéreux que l'achat d'un
véhicule neuf à peu près la moitié et
donc ça permettra à des populations qui
ont des moyens plus limités de d'accéder
à un transport propre avec une solution
de financement adaptée selon la dame le
rétrofit représente un marché français
potentiel d'un milliard d'euros pour
convertir 65000 véhicules thermiques en
véhicule électrique dans les cinq
prochaines années
voilà les voitures que vous allez voir
désormais ne changeront sûrement pas de
moteur tant elles sont précieuses pour
leur propriétaire Xavier Ory est un
passionné des années 60 et plus
particulièrement des voitures de cette
époque il en compte des dizaines dans
son garage et la rédaction de TL7 a eu
la chance de s'y rendre pour une
remontée dans le temps sans radar ni
péage regardez sur portail
en épicier en agriculteur ou bien encore
en adjudant chef de la gendarmerie
Xavier Auris est peut-être bien le seul
à pouvoir exercer tous ces métiers et en
même temps à 44 ans ce fan des années 60
fait vivre tous ses personnages à
travers sa passion la collection de
véhicules qui nous replonge dans les
sixties dans son hangar inferné Xavier
orienté tous ces véhicules près de 70
voitures ils sont précieusement abrités
dans sa collection on est surpris
d'abord par la dizaine de voitures de la
gendarmerie
bichonner et repeinte pour certaines le
collectionneur aime jouer le gendarme de
l'époque c'est aussi un métier que
j'aurais voulu faire tout à fait donc
voilà bah là aussi on se rattrape on se
rattrape avec les véhicules on se
retrouve avec l'ambiance on s'attrape
vient une association qui s'appelle
l'appétitg qui pour lequel on travaille
un petit peu avec la gendarmerie pour
faire des expos des choses comme ça s'il
n'a plus endosser l'uniforme aujourd'hui
il s'est bien rattrapé 4L estafette
bleue Peugeot 305 et bien d'autres
encore et le collectionneur ne lésigne
pas sur les détails ce bureau recréer
l'ambiance d'une brigade dans les années
60 avec tout le matériel d'époque que ce
soit tant au niveau de la du matériel
machin à écrire téléphone
plan diverses que les manuels de
gendarmerie que les procédures les
années 60 une époque qui fascine ce
quadra génère après avoir enfilé le
costume de gendarme il se met dans la
peau d'un épicier c'est à bord de cet
estafette qu'il aurait tant aimé
sillonner la campagne ligérienne
puisque bon ce véhicule a 6300 km il est
équipé comme une épicerie d'époque qui
passait un des villages années 60 et à
peu près de quoi se nourrir vous avez de
quoi boire tracteur mobylette camion et
même un corbillard complexe à collection
de voitures des années 60 depuis 30 ans
qu'il collectionne tous ses objets et
engins qui roulent Xavier Auris réalise
quelque part un rêve d'enfant
nostalgique des années yéyé cette digne
d'un musée amuse Xavier Auris
aujourd'hui il continue d'agrandir sa
collection un rythme beaucoup moins
soutenu qu'à une époque mais son esprit
grand enfant lui perdurera encore un bon
moment
[Musique]
dans trois semaines fini les vacances et
retour sur les campus pour les étudiants
malheureusement nombre d'entre eux sont
encore en recherche d'un logement pour
débuter l'année scolaire dans les
Yvelines une colocation d'un nouveau
genre existe depuis presque un an
celle-ci accueille des jeunes femmes en
situation de handicap mental une chance
pour elle de partager des moments entre
amis et de découvrir l'autonomie en
dehors du foyer familial un reportage
plein de bonne humeur de TV 78 la chaîne
des Yvelines
voilà bah super chambre c'est la maison
du bonheur dans cette grande bâtisse
flambant neuve cette femme en situation
de handicap mentale cohabite dans un
esprit familial chacune dispose de sa
propre chambre et salle de bain le salon
la buanderie ou encore la cuisine sont
eux des lieux communs le matin elle
prend les petits déjeuners et après elle
partent elles partent pour pour aller
travailler elle travaille toute la
journée en revanche le handicap ne leur
permet pas de vivre seul dans une dans
un appartement indépendant deux
maîtresses de maison aussi éducatrice
spécialisées se relaient pour les
superviser faire le lien avec les
familles et proposer des activités
jardinage jeux de société tâches
ménagères les sept colocataires
participent pleinement à la vie
quotidienne le jardin ça fait divers
parce que on se dépense on se dit foule
en faisant jardinage on n'oublie plus
facilement où on a mal certains de
essayer et récupérer le courrier
certains ne la cuisine mais de la
vaisselle matin et soir une maison qui a
comme objectifs de leur offrir un
maximum d'autonomie tout en brisant
l'isolement liée au handicap c'est comme
une famille
un peu partager
on peut avec un joyeux vivre on savait
use Henri on pleure on fait des choses
rigolotes une colocation ce qui est
sympa c'est d'être avec ses amis de
pouvoir partager des vies des moments
conviviaux se passent retrouver tout
seul le soir pour dîner un habitat à
taille humaine qui se présente comme une
alternative au foyer ou aux instituts
spécialisés une colocation du même style
existent également pour cette jeune
garçon à Versailles
sans transition prenons la direction de
la Martinique dans ce journal pour
parler de savoir-faire et de
transmission Robert Peyronnet et maître
Chaix depuis 30 ans dans une rhumerie
locale une expérience qui lui a permis
d'acquérir des compétences très
précieuses vous allez le voir pas tout à
fait à la retraite le Martiniquais
souhaite à présent transmettre ses
connaissances à la jeune génération
c'est un portrait signé de Tom Gagnoud
pour la rédaction de via TV en
Martinique
dans les caves de l'Habitation Clément
Robert surveille la fermentation de sa
progéniture des centaines de fûts d'où
surgit une douce mélodie de bois
à l'intérieur
repose le précieux nectar un rhum qui
repose depuis 6 mois ce rituel le maître
de chez l'exerce depuis plus de 30 ans
plus aucun breuvage ne dupe sont pas les
bonnes qualités et les arômes donc déjà
présents complètement perdu le côté et
une note de rhum blanc après 6 mois une
passion pour le rhum et un savoir-faire
précieux Robert ne pouvait partir sans
le transmettre
je suis énormément d'expérience il faut
le transmettre pour que la marque puisse
perdurer
31 même si le maître de chez a déjà cédé
sa place il veille au grain auprès des
jeunes recrues
Kevin a intégré l'équipe de chez il y a
trois ans c'est Robert qui lui a tout
appris 30 octobre
ça prend du temps aussi à apprendre donc
il faut être il faut se coller à lui je
pense pour avoir des connaissances
aujourd'hui la distillerie Clément
compte plus de 70 cubes répartis dans 6
chaises elle produit plus de 2 millions
de litres de rhum par an un rendement
acquis au fil des années Robert a vu
grandir l'exploitation
il n'y avait que ce bâtiment qui
existait donc le cher au meilleur climat
c'est la dent que nous avions
globalement un peu plus de 1500 fûts et
le domaine ne cesse de s'agrandir une
fierté pour celui qui a consacré sa vie
l'homme par serein mais quelque chose
nous dit qu'il n'en n'a pas encore fini
avec le rhum et estime que qu'il me
reste encore plein de choses à apprendre
donc vraiment c'est
un métier qui demande de la passion mais
on n'a jamais fini d'apprendre pour
saluer son travail les roms Clément ont
préparé une cuvée ultime au nom de
Robert
un rhum vieux d'excellence fait par le
maître lui-même qui promet dans soleil
et vos papilles
voici maintenant une belle histoire de
passation qui nous conduit désormais en
Île-de-France à la rencontre d'une
ancienne pépite du basket son nom c'est
Chuck Diop car la trentaine aujourd'hui
et qui a tutoyé de près les sommets de
son sport avant de devoir renoncer à sa
carrière professionnelle une mésaventure
sportives qu'il raconte dans un livre
récemment paru et auprès des jeunes de
sa ville qu'il entraîne désormais
reportage de Ryan Belly pour via 95 la
chaîne du Val-d'Oise
ils sont nombreux à courir après un même
rêve devenir basketteur professionnel à
Gonesse ces jeunes joueurs sont formés
par check Diop c'est ici que le
trentenaire a commencé le basket à l'âge
de 7 ans sélectionnez parmi les
meilleurs joueurs franciliens à 14 ans
puis repérer par Ron Stewart l'un des
coachs de Tony Parker check Diop a
touché du doigt le niveau professionnel
aujourd'hui il prend en charge des
entraînements au club de basket est Val
d'Oise avec l'envie de partager sa
passion pour moi transmettre aux plus
jeunes c'est c'est primordial tout ce
que j'ai appris dans le basket par les
grands entraîneurs j'ai comment dire
c'est c'est pas quelque chose que je
garde en moi c'est si je peux le
transmettre à un joueur que j'ai vu
faire un petit erreur et que cette
erreur là on en a parlé il faut que
j'arrive à lui à lui à lui à lui
retranscrire à lui retransmettre son
parcours singulier il le décrit dans une
autobiographie publiée cette année
intitulé Les 69 péripéties petit boulot
précaire problème financier et blessures
ont mis un frein à sa carrière mais
l'ancien joueur de niveau national
gardant lui des valeurs à inculquer chez
la nouvelle génération
ce jeudi soir à l'entraînement des
joueurs
âgés entre 14 et 15 ans il suivent à la
lettre les conseils de leur entraîneur
passés par le centre de formation
d'Orléans un modèle d'inspiration pour
Darren Eden et Cameron c'est lui qui
vous motive il nous parle nous permet de
m'améliorer toujours plus et de me
donner à fond à chaque fois à chaque
entraînement coach il nous a entraîné
franchement c'était très bien il y avait
de l'intensité il y avait du niveau de
jeu ça se voit qu'il était qu'il allait
devenir professionnel avant gendarme
réserviste et employée dans une
pépinière shake Diop espère à présent
rebondir et passer les sélections pour
faire partie de l'équipe nationale
militaire de basket
pour cela il lui faudra réussir son
concours interne l'occasion de prendre
une revanche sur un destin mouvementé
lui n'est pas vraiment un sport mais
davantage un loisir le beatbox le nom de
ce jeu de plein air ne vous dit
peut-être rien il pourrait pourtant bien
tôt animer vos sorties au parc inventé
par un Toulousain ce jeu est un mélange
de pétanque et de palets breton 100%
français le secret du bebop est basé sur
le lancer de morceaux de bois pour en
savoir plus écouter les explications de
son créateur au micro de nos partenaires
de la Dépêche du Midi sur place
donc Bbox c'est un jeu qui allie champs
ses talents et il est composé de 8
palais qu'on appelle des bocs et d'un
bocs
ici présent donc du coup le jeu oppose
deux équipes l'équipe bleue face à
l'équipe rouge le but étant d'être
l'équipe la plus proche du maître pour
marquer des points voire de grimper sur
celui-ci pour maximiser le nombre de ses
points mais attention à ne pas retourner
c'est pas les car sinon on va donner des
points à l'équipe adverse
voilà cela demandera encore un peu de
pratique pour bien maîtriser les règles
du beatbox mais on va y arriver elle
maîtrise elle la création d'abat-jour
comme personne au monde dans les Vosges
une habitante est devenue une
spécialiste des luminaires grâce à la
confection d'abat-jour végétaux une
passion devenue une profession avec une
clientèle répartie dans toute la France
et dans le monde entier un reportage
d'Aurélie Colombel et d'Hélène le plat à
la rencontre de cette femme pour rejeter
les visions
panier à la main Daniel fait le tour de
son jardin cet écrin de verdure à ce nom
j'approximité de Vittel lui offre le
terrain de jeu idéal pour sa cueillette
qui donne le meilleur effet parce que
elle elles ont du un grain dans la
feuille inspiré par le jardin de
berchies Granges cette ex-parisienne
s'installe avec son époux dans les
Vosges en 2013 elle décora alors sa
demeure avec des luminaires fait main en
prenant des textiles de grands créateurs
comme Pierre frais et Canova si ces
tissus sont tellement splendides c'est
parce que ils ont longtemps regardé la
richesse des couleurs et la finesse des
feuillages et des fleurs donc en fait
j'ai retrouvé un petit peu les sources
de leur inspiration et j'essaye de
rendre avec des feuillages le caractère
précieux de ces grands tissus de retour
du jardin Daniel laissé chez au moins
une semaine sa cueillette ensuite les
serviront dans la confection d'abat-jour
et autres décors d'intérieur je suis une
autodidacte et absolument
ceci dit j'ai travaillé
il y a très longtemps dans la
restauration de tableaux anciens j'ai
travaillé beaucoup sur les natures
mortes et les tableaux de fleurs
flamands du XVIIe et je pense qu'il y a
des réminiscences un travail minutieux
et des pièces uniques que Daniel a
d'abord vendu un cercle d'amis avant de
monter sa propre société lazuli biloba
via la plateforme Etsy et son site
internet ses abat-jours sont achetés
partout dans le monde américain et
danois semble particulièrement intéressé
après sur la qualité des tissus français
celui-ci vient des ateliers Boussac un
abat-jour dans un beau tissu ça fait
comme une sculpture lumineuse donc en
fait on peut entièrement meubler décorer
une maison ou un appartement avec des
luminaires au vu de son succès
l'entreprise que l'asuli biloba ne
demande qu'à grandir Daniel recherche
d'ailleurs un collaborateur pour créer
des pieds de lampes inspirés par les
végétaux
allez partons non loin de la Suisse pour
découvrir l'un des plus beaux complexes
hôteliers du monde Leviant Resort situé
en Haute-Savoie et notamment connu pour
son Florent l'hôtel Royal sa vue sur le
lac Léman constitue un atout
impérissable malgré le temps aujourd'hui
encore cet hôtel accueille de nombreuses
personnalités artistiques ou politiques
Victoria Lopez de la rédaction de 8
Mont-Blanc a poussé les portes de ce
luxueux palace pour nous regardez
au début du XXème siècle les bains de
mer n'existaient pas la bourgeoisie
européenne raffole à l'époque des lacs
et des eaux thermales pour l'accueillir
la Société des Eaux construit un palace
sur les hauteurs des viandes il ouvre
ses portes en 1909 c'était très fort en
marketing déjà à l'époque parce qu'il
s'était aperçu que si on a tiré les
belles personnes fatalement ça attire ré
encore plus de clientèle et le dandy de
l'époque au niveau européen c'était
Edouard VII le roi d'Angleterre donc ils
sont dit on va appeler l'hôtel Royal
royal en l'honneur de sa Majesté le roi
d'Angleterre en lui disant écoutez votre
Majesté nous serons très heureux de vous
recevoir et il avait dit oui sauf que
malheureusement le pauvre est décédé en
10 et donc on ne l'a jamais vu mais par
contre la couine même est venue elle ici
au Royal et donc on avait quand même une
présence couronnée anglaise ici même une
suite et un salon porte toujours
aujourd'hui le nom d'Edouard VII depuis
des dizaines de personnalité ont marqué
l'histoire du palace parmi elles
l'acteur australo-américain Errol Flynn
grand nom de l'âge d'or hollywoodien il
était là au moment où l'hôtel a eu son
incendie il y a eu un incendie en 57 et
rolphine s'est retrouvé sur la pelouse
suite à l'incendie Sacha Guitry aussi a
été un personnage du Royal il aimait
beaucoup et puis effectivement la
politique a marqué
la destination déjà Évian puisque vous
savez en 2003 Jacques Chirac avait
décidé de faire son son G8 ici même à
Évian et c'est donc au Royal que les
présidents se sont tous retrouvés avec
une salle de réunion ici même qu'on
appelle toujours G8 d'ailleurs par la
suite là tous les présidents français
sont venus sans exception voilà jusqu'à
notre président actuel ici même Royal
l'histoire du Royal est aussi intimement
liée du sport et particulièrement du
golf les Vian Resort propriétaires du
palace possèdent en effet le terrain
situé à quelques pas d'ici un parcours
mondialement réputé qui accueille un des
cinq tournois internationaux majeurs
féminins la Grange aux lac celle de
concerts particulièrement apprécié des
musiciens est également propriété du
complexe hôtelier elle inscrit pour sa
part la musique dans l'ADN de
l'établissement
rénové en 2015 l'hôtel Royal continue
d'écrire les pages de son histoire entre
Green et partition derrière les portes
de ces 150 chambres
certains l'appellent l'incarnat connu et
reconnu pour ses qualités dans le monde
entier le marbre rouge du Languedoc orne
certains des plus beaux édifices du
monde la basilique Saint-Pierre de Rome
ou le château de Versailles on est
composé ce marbre unique et précieux et
extrait de la Montagne Noire de l'Aude
ainsi étonnant et titanesque dans lequel
nous emmène Anne-Sophie pellegrid pour
la rédaction de vie Occitanie regardez
ce reportage
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le plateau des terralb
sur le piémont Minervois de la Montagne
Noire dans l'Aude
c'est d'ici que proviennent les marbres
qui ornent le Grand Trianon à Versailles
et la plupart des édifices religieux et
maison bourgeoises d'Occitanie
cette carrière est exploitée par la
société Cyrnos chaque année Antonio et
son équipe extrait de La Roche 10000
tonnes de marbre chaque bloc pèse à lui
seul près de 800 tonnes un travail
titanesque réalisé à l'aide d'une si
longue de 3 mètres permettant de
désolidariser la roche du sol
[Musique]
la roche haute de 15 mètres afin d'y
glisser un câble
est composé de diamant qui permet de
découper la paroi il faut y ajouter de
l'eau car sans eau il est impossible de
découper on glisse le câble du haut de
la paroi jusqu'en bas on le tire
jusqu'au milieu de la place ensuite on
met la machine en marche sur les rails
tout doit être en place au moins
dignement et que la paroi soit toujours
ouverte en 2020 une touriste a filmé la
chute d'une plaque de marbre dont les
blocs étaient destinés à la rénovation
de la basilique Saint-Pierre de Rome oh
là là là là
on appelle cette pierre l'Incarna ou
marbo rouge du Languedoc le marbre le
plus prestigieux et le plus connu en
France grâce à la proximité du canal du
Midi l'incarnasse exporta dans toute
l'Europe très appréciée par Louis XIV et
notamment l'église qui voyait dans la
pierre la couleur rouge de la Passion du
Christ associée au blanc symbole de
pureté mais il n'est pas le seul type de
marbre que renferme les carrières de
cône il y a le Turquin le gris le
cervelas au total 17 faciès se décline
et s'étend dans le Minervois sur 16 km
parcourant les communes de cônes
Villeneuve et félines sous chacune
d'entre elles c'est près de 400 mètres
de couches de marbre qui repose
derrière chaque trace il y a un marteau
un burin un geste gravé dans la pierre
pour les siècles
les marrières de Caunes Minervois sont
en accès libre des visites sont
organisées par l'association des
marbrières de Caunes sur réservation
auprès de l'Office de Tourisme grand
Carcassonne antenne de code Minervois
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand JT des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]